[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
por tercera vez en 13 años el gobierno
de nicolás maduro reconvirtió la moneda
venezolana
esta vez le quito 6 ceros al bolívar
para hacer frente a la hiperinflación y
la dificultad para realizar
transacciones el régimen de venezuela
espera además con esto incentivar la
moneda digital en auge por la escasez de
billetes precisamente causada por la
inflación endémica les contamos desde
caracas
y cientos de muertos dejó un motín en
una cárcel de guayaquil se trata del
peor de la historia de ecuador el
presidente guillermo lasso declaró el
estado de emergencia en todo el sistema
penitenciario para hacer frente a la
crisis pues la revuelta se dio entre
bandas rivales que operan desde las
prisiones y se disputan el control de
las rutas del narcotráfico hacia el
norte del continente les contamos cómo
opera
y la semana en washington estuvo marcada
por la posibilidad de caer en un cierre
de gobierno o sad down debido a la
imposibilidad del congreso de llegar a
un acuerdo sobre el presupuesto para el
nuevo año fiscal y el techo de la deuda
les explicamos que es este límite de la
capacidad de endeudamiento en eeuu
y vamos a venezuela para nuestra cifra
de la semana que habían podrían ser 26
porque el banco central de venezuela le
quitó 6 ceros a la moneda y ahora un
millón de bolívares es sólo 1 o 14
porque con esta nueva reconversión
monetaria la tercera desde 2007 se le
han quitado 14 ceros al bolívar lo que
refleja la inflación endémica y la
devaluación de la moneda pues ese millón
de bolívares o ahora un bolívar equivale
a 25 centavos de dólar con el nuevo cono
monetario el gobierno de nicolás maduro
tiene impulsar además las transacciones
virtuales que están en auge en venezuela
debido a la escasez de billetes que
generó la inflación nuestra corresponsal
en caracas miquel coll esther nos cuenta
más de estos sistemas informales de pago
en el país
esta tienda en caracas ya se abrió al
uso de cryptome unidas bitcoin estéreo
ondas aunque santiago asegura que las
transacciones inscripto aún son pocas
repente al mes 23 personas
como sea la fiebre del bitcoin ha
llegado en eso el ángulo en este café
por ejemplo se ofrece en cursos sobre
cripto economía el problema fundamental
es educar para que las personas
entiendan que eso es accesible que es
una herramienta que en el caso de los
venezolanos que vivimos en una economía
hiperinflacionaria nos puede ayudar a
resguardar nuestros bolívares
transformándolo por ejemplo en dólares
digitales tras la pérdida de valor del
bolívar local los venezolanos adoptaron
un sistema informal de pago con
múltiples monedas la propia
hiperinflación y la dolarización
hicieron que ahora tengamos no solamente
dólares y nueve euros sino pesos
colombianos reales brasileros y hasta el
oro y los cripto activos se suman a todo
esto esta pensionada recibió el año
pasado un bono social de 0.5 metros la
cuestionada cripto moneda que el
gobierno creó en 2018 y respaldada por
las riquezas petroleras del país son
unos 30 dólares no le gusta sólo puede
cambiarlos en bancos estatales y no en
el mercado internacional para los
grandes capitales puede ser beneficioso
pero para los que necesitamos el dinero
diariamente para poder subsistir
no no le veo gran ventaja
en la calle el favorito es el dólar al
bolívar un día vale una cosa y el otro
día otra cosa y una moneda que ya están
destruidas que
no ya no sirve pues
este primero de octubre el bolívar
perdió seis ceros como parte de un nuevo
proceso de reconversión monetaria es el
tercero desde 2008 en total son 14 0 son
los que se le han suprimido a esta
moneda destruida por la inflación en
caracas nicole holter france24
y al menos 120 presos fallecidos deja un
motín en una cárcel de guayaquil en
ecuador la policía y el ejército
asumieron el control del centro
penitenciario por orden del presidente
guillermo lasso que dijo que la revuelta
se debió a una disputa entre bandas
rivales por el control de las rutas del
narcotráfico que operan desde las
prisiones les explicamos cómo en el
siguiente informe
las autoridades ecuatorianas aseguran
que el motín en la cárcel de guayaquil
se registró entre los choneros y los
lobos dos bandas criminales afiliadas a
los cárteles mexicanos de sinaloa y de
jalisco nueva generación
respectivamente y es que grupos
criminales de méxico colombia y brasil
se han disputado durante años el control
de las presiones de américa latina' que
son la base de operaciones para
coordinar el tráfico de drogas y otras
actividades delincuenciales
guayaquil es la principal ciudad
portuaria de ecuador y es utilizada como
un centro de distribución de la cocaína
producida en sudamérica hacia el norte
del continente de hecho las autoridades
mexicanas y colombianas han identificado
al menos siete rutas de narcotráfico
entre ecuador y colombia con destino a
centroamérica y méxico dos de ellas
parten desde las costas del pacífico
colombiano hacia costa rica el salvador
y guatemala
una tercera sale desde esmeraldas en
ecuador con destino a guatemala en
méxico la cuarta despegan san lorenzo
hacia las costas mexicanas de oaxaca y
guerrero dos más salen desde puerto rico
en ecuador hacia michoacán guerrero
jalisco y sinaloa la última vía conecta
a la anp ecuador con las playas
sinaloenses tan solo en los
departamentos de nariño y putumayo en
colombia se producen alrededor de 400
toneladas de drogas al año el 50% es
trasladado a ecuador para utilizar
dichas rutas en el primer trimestre de
2021 fueron decomisadas 93 toneladas de
drogas en territorio ecuatoriano dos
veces más que en el mismo período de
el congreso de eeuu evitó a última hora
el cierre del gobierno o shot down horas
antes del inicio del nuevo año fiscal
republicanos y demócratas no habían
aprobado los fondos para que las
oficinas federales continuaran operando
lo que hubiera paralizado a miles de
trabajadores en el centro de la disputa
estaba el techo de la deuda un mecanismo
que regularmente es elevado por el
congreso pero su simple existencia deja
la unión americana expuesta a caer en
sensación de pagos de sus obligaciones y
cargar consigo a la economía mundial
veamos más en el siguiente informe
una bomba de tiempo económica cuya mecha
reinicia constantemente incluido por
primera vez en 1917 para darle al
departamento del tesoro margen de
maniobra para emitir bonos el techo de
la deuda es un tope sobre la cantidad
que el gobierno federal puede pedir para
pagar sus facturas
dado que eeuu generalmente tiene déficit
presupuestario significativos su deuda
aumenta constantemente sólo los
intereses llegarán trescientos setenta y
ocho mil millones de dólares para 2021
elevar el techo de la deuda no autoriza
ni facilitan nuevos gastos sólo permite
que eeuu continúe pidiendo prestado para
cumplir con sus obligaciones actuales
desde 1960 el congreso ha elevado el
techo de la deuda 78 veces pero las
últimas décadas han visto una mayor
polarización y una reducción de la
cooperación entre republicanos y
demócratas en 2006 los demócratas
votaron en contra de elevar la capacidad
de endeudamiento citando un déficit
inmenso causado por los recortes de
impuestos de bus y las invasiones a
oriente medio pero no fueron
obstruccionistas en agosto de 2019 el
congreso con apoyo bipartidista
suspendió el techo de la deuda hasta
julio de 2021 después de que los
republicanos agregarán billones a la
deuda a través de los recortes de
impuestos nuestro amp de 2017 este
agosto el techo se elevó a 28.4 billones
de dólares pero la deuda nacional
asciende actualmente a
28.43 billones de dólares lo que
significa que el tesoro ha estado
utilizando medidas excepcionales
transfiriendo fondos de un sector a otro
para pagar las facturas esas
transferencias no pueden continuar para
siempre y si el tesoro se queda sin
dinero las consecuencias serían nefastas
por lynn millones de estadounidenses
dejarían de recibir los beneficios de
seguro social y de medicare las tropas y
los empleados federales dejarían de
recibir sus salarios
eeuu no podría pagar intereses sobre sus
bonos existentes tal incumplimiento de
la deuda no tendría precedentes dañando
la calificación crediticia de eeuu y la
posición del dólar como la principal
moneda de reserva internacional la
mayoría de los países no tienen un
límite de deuda y creciente riesgo de
cesación de pago en los últimos años ha
llevado a muchos a considerar
de eeuu pero eso requeriría una ley
bipartidista en el congreso y por ahora
el límite de deuda está atrapado en
maniobras políticas a corto plazo pero
tiene la mayor cifra de muertes por kobe
y 19 por cada 100.000 habitantes 9.2 sin
embargo esta semana con el avance de la
vacunación
las cifras empezaron a mejorar y por
ejemplo en lima la capital no se
registraron ni una sola muerte por
coronavirus el domingo 26 de septiembre
por primera vez desde el inicio de la
pandemia
poco a poco el turismo empieza a
reactivarse un bálsamo en cusco donde
está ubicado el legendario machu picchu
cuya economía depende en gran medida de
los visitantes
ubicada en los andes peruanos la ciudad
de cusco era la capital del imperio inca
es uno de los lugares más turísticos de
perú pero durante varios meses de 2020
la pandemia de kobe 19 evitó que los
turistas pisaron su suelo los cusqueños
que dependen en gran medida del turismo
se vieron gravemente afectados
no estoy preparado tenía un trabajo día
a día entonces cuando llegó la pandemia
me quedé sin trabajo
primero entramos tres meses de
cuarentena y bueno eso fue difícil para
mí porque todo ese tiempo vivía de mi
ahorro las medidas de seguridad para
evitar la propagación del cob y 19 están
siendo levantadas una a una y los
turistas están regresando lentamente
los dueños de las tiendas son optimistas
pero esperan que las cosas regresen a
cómo eran antes de la pandemia
[Música]
felizmente ahora ya todo está cambiando
pero ahora el turismo solamente es
nacional en la gran parte son nacionales
el turismo internacional se ve pero muy
poco y esperemos que sea con el tiempo
pues mejore también es baja porque el
turismo internacional siempre siempre no
tengo como le digo siempre nos beneficia
en parte a todos machu picchu ubicado a
tres horas de cusco es uno de los
lugares más populares de américa latina-
la antigua ciudad inca fue construida en
el siglo 15 y aún cautiva a arqueólogos
y visitantes machu picchu es
emocionante y para cualquier visitante
turista de cualquier parte del mundo va
a ser un lugar bien atrás pero en más
que todo cultural en machu picchu la
capacidad límite de turistas ha sido
reducida dramáticamente para cumplir con
el distanciamiento social pero las
medidas han sido gradualmente levantadas
incluso a pesar de que las visitas
masivas pueden dañar el lugar hay daños
e incluso se vea evidencia de que se
puede ver puede ocasionar desgaste en
las piedras por las caminatas que se has
el turismo es crucial para perú el
producto interno bruto del país cayó más
de 11 por ciento en 2020 y se estima que
la pandemia ha llevado a una caída de
más del 70% de la actividad turística
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí a américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estudio joan y agudelo sigan
con más en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]